hey youtubers it's Charlie so I hope
you've all had a chance to see the Game
of Thrones season 4 finale but now it's
time to talk about season 5 and I think
the most interesting conversation isn't
so much you know what they're gonna do
from the books it's more what they're
gonna change from the books and how
that's gonna affect the story going
forward so Dan and Dave said that you
know they changed some big things this
season but even more things are gonna
change next season so what I'm gonna do
in this video is just go down the cast
list and talk a little bit about what I
would like to see from each character
next season I'll make sure to say if
someone had a bunch of changes this
season from the books because that will
affect what happens to them in the
future for the most part there were only
a few characters that had really big
significant changes so what I'm gonna do
is start with the characters we saw in
the finale first just because we saw the
most recently and then I'll circle back
around and get the other main characters
that we haven't seen in a couple
episodes also if I feel like this video
starts to get a little too long I'll
just break some of the smaller
characters off and do them in another
video in the future be sure to subscribe
to get everything
I try to keep videos from going longer
than like twelve or thirteen minutes I
know a lot of you guys want really long
videos but I feel like there's a certain
limit to that also in case you didn't
see if there's still time to enter the
giveaway just make sure you watch the
finale video I just posted after you
watch this it's really simple it's not a
contest or anything but I'll put a link
in the description for it so here we go
careful for spoilers from the finale if
you haven't seen it yet and just a quick
note on potential book spoilers for
season 5 because we are talking about
season 5 most of the conclusions that I
make are just based on clues that Dan
and Dave seated in the episodes this
season
so I'm not going to go too far into the
books or do any super book spoilers or
anything like that so here we go
starting with Tyrion and Varys who are
basically travel companions now there
were a few callbacks to season two and
three scenes in those final moments of
theirs first was the box all I could
think about was very sorcerer that he
captured that was the exact same type of
box that Tyrion climbed into and then
there were the bells I felt like this
was a stronger call back Faris always
said that he hated the ringing of bells
because they always rank for something
terrible like an attack on the city or
the death of a king Tyrion made a joke
saying that bells also rang for weddings
I guess you could consider that a moment
of foreshadowing for the red wedding
which hadn't even happened at that point
but weddings on Game of Thrones are
pretty horrific the boat they're headed
on is headed east
just because nowhere else in Westeros is
safe for them right now Fair's probably
would have been fine but remember how he
had been working to strengthen the realm
Cersei is in charge now that Tywin's
gone
she won't have to marry Loras and Tywin
won't be there to stop her from
indulging her every whim
so Varys would not have a very easy time
dealing with her so part of the reason
he left I think is also because he
didn't want to deal with Cersei on to
number two Cersei and Jaime Cersei as
discussed will figure out she's in
charge again and put the brakes on
anything she doesn't like on the bonus
side she'll be able to spend all her
time watching over Tommen and sir pounce
I'll say sir pounce is someone that I
hope they include at least once next
year the director of the episode that
did surpass said that we shouldn't
expect him back but I think it would be
a lot of fun
Jaime is probably gonna continue to try
and do things to get himself into the
white book or get more glorious deeds
into the white book but because Cersei
has free rein now she's probably going
to try and continue the twincest it's a
pretty toxic love that they have so I
fully expect him to flip-flop back and
forth all season just speaking as a fan
I would really like to see Jaime get to
the place where he's a really honorable
person like Brienne but george RR martin
and Dan and Dave could totally decided
that that is not in the cards for him
number three up at the wall Stannis
Melisandre and Jon Snow Stannis has a
massive army they're now paid for with
the iron banks money a lot of their
money it's actually big enough to man
some of those other castles along the
wall so I really hope that they build
sets for those other locations like the
Nightfort it's also possible that just
to save money they could spend all their
time at Castle black
but Game of Thrones is pretty good about
building new sets for big location so I
really hope we see some of those other
castles Melisandre gave Jon that really
long stare through the flames any time
she stares at someone it either means
she's gonna have sex with them at some
point or use them as some horrific plot
or in the case of gand rape both until
we learn a little bit more about the war
with the White Walkers I'm just looking
forward to her digging her claws into
him Melisandre has always said that
Stannis is azor Ahai but I'd love to see
her put that on Jon Snow
he and Stan has shared that long look of
understanding about burning the body so
he understands the threat of the White
Walkers but I don't expect Jon to
completely buy into anything Melisandre
might see in her flames as regards him
and the important thing to remember
about her visions are that Jojen said
that only green dreams
true a hundred percent of the time so
her visions could just be of things that
may have happened not always things that
will happen
number four on two brands group it seems
like a lot of you guys were more
interested in talking about jochen's
death as it affects the story more than
what was going on with bran so I'll
start with that
all the judging stuff that happened in
the books after they arrived at the tree
is in dance with dragon so brand story
on the show was taken a lot from that
book he doesn't really appear in book
for that much books four and five
occurred during the same time period
though so it's like one giant book split
into two in the book Jojen still has
visions of his death it just happens in
a different way so on the show when the
three-eyed raven said that Jojen always
knew he was gonna die he was just
acknowledging that future fate i think
the show changed jochen's death just to
be more efficient i don't think they
intended to use him in season five from
a story standpoint he served his purpose
he was only there to help brand reach
the three-eyed raven which he did and as
for his sister Meera she's basically
done to she was mostly jochen's
caregiver since she's still alive i
think she'll stay and help bran with
Hodor
although brand won't really need Hodor
as much since they are in the cave the
way i look at that child of the forest
is as being like a Hodor to the
three-eyed raven like a support person
so she's probably also gonna start
helping brand to number five Arya Stark
she's one of the few characters that's
traveling on her own Gendry being the
other big one that comes to mind
you know just someone who's not
traveling with another main character
her ship is headed to Braavos so she's
probably gonna try and look up Jack and
Hagar because she doesn't really know
that many people that are from Braavos
quick shout out for Syrio Forel
but because arias story is a huge part
of the books that the show has not done
yet please be careful if you want to
comment about book spoilers I won't say
what happens to her character but I
predict that the show will follow her
story from the book pretty closely so if
you haven't read the books yet and you
want to read about Aria's character
going forward you should start with arya
chapter one in book four that's feast
for crows she's a POV character in book
four the first chapter of her takes
place immediately after the last scene
with her in the finale so if anyone
wants to read the books during the
hiatus book four would be a really good
place to start if you don't want to read
the first three books I understand a lot
of you guys don't care about reading the
books at all you just want to watch the
show and that's totally cool I'm totally
fine with that number six
and Podrick so Brienne is still alive
and mostly well after her fight with the
hound they changed her plot in the book
significantly but I think she's just
gonna resume her search for Sansa and
head towards the bloody gate if they do
end up making it there I don't think
they're gonna find Sansa I think she'll
be long gone
leading me on to number seven Sansa and
Littlefinger back when black hair Sansa
was saying shall we go she was referring
to Littlefinger's plan to take Robin
Arryn on a tour of his holdings so
they're just gonna head out and start
travelling around the Vale if you look
at the map here it's actually pretty big
so there are a number of places they can
visit but they're probably going to
spend most of season five just traveling
around trying to avoid other characters
number eight on to reek and Ramsay
Bolton a lot of Theon or Brik stories
you want to think about him came from
dance with dragons like the moat Cailin
stuff but there's still a lot of it that
they haven't done from the books yet so
I'll say the same thing I did for arias
book story please be careful if you want
to comment about spoilers but I expect
them to also follow Theon story from the
books pretty closely so if you want to
read reek story from the books but you
don't want to read book for don't worry
because they're both occurring in the
same period of time so you're not really
spoiling yourself you're not like
jumping forward in time but it starts
with reek chapter two and dance with
dragons that's basically where the show
left off this season that's pretty much
it for the biggest characters I know we
haven't seen bran in a long time but
he's mostly porking his new wife lollies
he still listed as a main cast member on
the show so we will see him in any
King's Landing stories next year since
there are a billion secondary characters
we can just discuss them in the comments
so if there's someone that you wanted to
talk about that I didn't put in the
video just write them in in the comments
I know a lot of you are asking about two
very specific big book characters that
the show did not do and just to answer
you without being too spoilery for
people who don't know about him no I do
not think we're gonna see them in the
future
the director of the finale said that
they were never on the table whenever
they were in the story phase whenever
they were playing the episodes out they
never talked about including them so
that doesn't mean they absolutely won't
do them in the future but I'm not
expecting them to and on the topic of
books changes Dan and Dave said even
more things would be changing in season
five but mostly what I think will change
is which characters run into each other
I think we'll see a few unexpected
run-ins with people in Braavos and
eventually marine Braavos is a lot
closer to Westeros so I'm hoping we see
kendry there but his character has
changed so much from the books as
hard to tell where we'll see him next
and I've already spent a lot of time
talking about the new characters and
Dorne in the Martel's so if you want to
watch that video all I did is a link in
the description but yes we will see a
lot of door nick season they are filming
in Spain I'm really excited about that
so my next video is gonna be the Q&A
I'll try to post it by tonight but
usually I post updates on social so just
follow me on Twitter or Facebook if you
want to find out how the video is coming
along in real life matters I'm actually
gonna be going to VidCon this year so if
you guys are going and you want to do a
meet-up or anything just let me know and
I'll try to arrange something but I'm
going to be posting a separate VidCon
video that explains what's going on so
right now click here for my Q&A I'll add
an annotation as soon as I post it and
click here for my finale video thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives
[Music]
you